I wanted to read you a quote it's a
quote that I I love uh it's by Vladimir
Lenin I don't think he gets quoted a lot
here at the White House but I'm going to
go for it there are decades where
nothing happens and weeks where
everything happens you are living
through an extraordinary time as
president it feels like the world is
turning on its axis every 36 hours are
there times when you wake up on the in
the morning and think I wish it was a
little bit duller right now I wish
things would just settle down well yes
and no look yes when I had that cranial
anism the doc was trying to explain to
me whether it was congenital or
environmental and I said doc I don't
care just fix it yeah this is back in is
this 88 this is 88 and he looked at me
said you know what your problem is
Senator and I said no doc I said you're
a congenital Optimist well seriously I
was a quote here here's the deal though
one of the things that I've never been
more optimistic about America's chances
in my whole life I wasn't going to run
again because I just lost my son he
should be sitting being interviewed not
me he was the Attorney General bronze
star winner Major in the USR anyway yeah
when I wasn't going to run because I was
going to write a book on an inflection
point in American history I think we're
at one of those points that every 7even
or eight Generations occurs yeah where
the not because of any one leader but
the world is changing everything's in
motion and what we do in the last couple
years the next three or four years is
going to determine the course of the
country and the world for the next five
or six decades I believe that with every
fiber of my being yeah if we prevent
Ukraine from collapsing if we continue
I've worked like hell not just me to
hold NATO together tightly it's never
been this tight expand it we have an
opportunity to change the dynamic in
Europe for Generations yeah my mother
God lover I remember going to identify
my family they actually Joey out of
everything terrible something good will
happen if you look hard enough for it I
thought it was the cruelest thing she
ever said to me but look what's going on
in the Middle East now yeah you know I
was able to get a resolution passed
through the G20 the 20 leaders of the 20
largest nations to build a railroad from
Riad all the way through into Saudi
Arabia Jordan up through Israel all the
way all the way up until into Europe
because there's much more reason for
them to be together than to be aart I'm
not a journalist so I'm allowed to give
my opin opion and uh I as a again
amateur historian I think it's
absolutely crucial that Ukraine Prevail
and uh it's it's something that I'm very
passionate about I get
confused you know as you know the
Washington UK came to in the
1973 uh Republicans were always tough on
foreign policy tough on Russia and now
mag Republicans they've kind of flipped
the script and uh they're saying well we
can let Ukraine go it's not really uh in
our interest and I don't understand it
it's confusing to me also say the other
guy says and we can work with Putin he's
smart the other guy I like that he's the
other
guy he's like Voldemort now his name
shall not be mentioned
well good point yeah I plead guilty yeah
but look I mean just if nothing but
global warming it's changing the world
yeah ice caps are melting that's true
but guess what brings that along with
now you got China and Russia and the
north pole trying to circumvent the
globe change the dynamic in the region I
mean it's the things that are happening
for example the idea that we're having
to rebuild infrastructure but some
countries don't have the capacity to do
it I've been met now twice I've had the
leaders of the Pacific Nations come and
be with me here because they're worried
about going underwater not making it
just go down the list but I think maybe
because I'm that congen Optimist when I
told told my staff a couple years ago I
was going to bring South Korea and Japan
together they looked at me like now look
I know a fair amount about foreign
policy I have more experience than any
president's ever had doesn't mean I'm
good or bad just I I know these excuse
me heads of state it is it's a small
world it's getting smaller and smaller
yeah for example in the you know China
China's a competitor but I have a
relationship with xingping I've spent
more time with them than any world
leader ever has just because when I was
vice president Barack wanted me to get
to know him because a pres wasn't
appropriate for a president to spend
time with him because but we knew he was
going to be the president he's a very
tough smart guy but he's got enormous
problems and so for example when I put
together the quad India Japan austral
the United States he said you're trying
to surround me I'm not trying to
surround you I said we're just not going
to let you change the dynamic of world
rules so whether it's International
airspace or whether it's sea space they
said well I didn't write them I said
well that's what they are we're not
going to change them so many parts are
moving that there's an opportunity to
realign the world in a way that is less
likely to result in war less likely to
result in human suffering now I know
people look at me and say well you're
just too optimistic I think it takes
some real planning and there's ways to
step up and lead and look one of the
things is again I want to make it clear
it's not because Joe Biden's president
it's the moment mine Albright said
America is the essential Nation Conan
that's not a joke who leads the world if
the United States
doesn't who who no one else can and we
have an obligation and an enormous
opportunity to leave our kids and our
grandkids a better world well I like
that you describe yourself as an
optimist congenital Optimist I would say
I'm a I've always tell people I'm a 52%
Optimist meaning I'm I'm there's a good
healthy dose of me that is very worried
and very concerned but I always lean
towards optimism it's the more
challenging standpoint to take well
don't get me wrong I I have written
about and I think I know pretty
intimately the downside yeah but look we
got to remember we're the United States
of America for God's sake nothing
nothing nothing is beyond our capacity
when we work together I mean it really
isn't think if we're the only nation of
the world in my view as a student of
history that has come out of every
crisis stronger than we went in I didn't
want to end on I've been doing this for
a long time and so it was a big honor
when I got the call that day the the
president of the United States uh was
going to speak to me in the White House
and uh it's um you know it's a it's it's
an honor and uh I'm rooting for you and
as the Irish say God bless you you know
thank you thank you for taking the time
to do this do you guys have a chance to
come over and see the oval I'd love to
see the oval come on let's go do it all
right let's do
it